[Music]
all right what's up MKBHD here and today
it was a pretty exciting day today was
Apple's October event and really I'm
just gonna call it their MacBook Pro
event now of course I'm gonna try to
stay neutral and measured about all this
stuff I'm not about to just jump right
in and say hey this is the greatest
laptop ever made because it's very
expensive and clearly it's not for
everybody but for me as a as a final cut
editor this was a laptop that I was
waiting for the most this is the one
that applies to me the most and my
workflow and the stuff that I do here at
the studio every week so I was excited
for it so let's just go right through
everything first of all they did open up
the event it wasn't just MacBook Pros
there was some audio stuff too so
there's a new Apple Subscription Service
basically a lower tier of Apple music
through Siri that's five bucks a month
there's some new homepod Mini colors and
also there's a new third generation
airpods so there's a new design that
basically looks just like airpods Pro
but without the Silicon tips and the
noise cancellation and they have a new
wider case with magsafe wireless
charging and a longer battery life and
they're 179 bucks definitely get
subscribed to stay tuned for that full
review and I get those in my hands here
but then we got right to the good stuff
right into the new Apple silicon so the
M1 chip which seems like pretty recent
but we've had for a little while now was
a pretty huge jump right from all the
Intel stuff that was in Max before this
was the first time we were getting Apple
silicon inside Apple machines and all
that integration gave us much better
performance and much better efficiency
in the MacBook Air and the MacBook Pro
13 in these iMacs in the Mac Mini it was
even in an iPad Pro
but after all that stuff came out all
this Baseline stuff is covered and it
left us wondering when are we going to
see the stuff at a pro level some higher
end Apple silicon for the really intense
workflows because we still had Intel
chips in the higher end MacBook Pro and
so we were looking for higher end
aposilicon for the higher end bigger
machines and so that's what we finally
got we actually got two new Chips
there's M1 Pro
and M1 Max
yeah kind of cheesy names at first but
they do make sense so this is the
upgrade this is Apple silicon Unleashed
you might say so the M1 Pro chip has a
10 core CPU eight high performance with
two high efficiency and a 16 core GPU
with up to 32 gigs of RAM which doesn't
sound like a lot but keep in mind this
is just the first tier Pro chip same
shared memory architecture still built
on the five nanometer process but it's
basically simply a physically scaled up
M1 chip as expected and they're saying
it will deliver 70 faster CPU
performance and 100 faster GPU
performance over the M1 the already
really good M1 which was The Head and
Shoulders over the Intel chips that came
before it which is pretty crazy but then
now there's also M1 Max which again
scaled up even further and it's mostly
in the GPU department so it's a bigger
system on a chip look at the size of
that chip and this time it's the same 10
core CPU but up to 3 32 cores of GPU and
up to 64 gigs of shared memory so now
you have four times the m1's graphic
capability so this answers the question
I first had when we first started
getting M1 Max which is okay those are
replacing all the systems with
integrated gpus but what about when they
get to the bigger systems that have
dedicated graphics cards are they going
to continue to have dedicated graphics
cards or will they build it all in
and of course in the laptop World it
makes sense for efficiency's sake to
just build it all in so that's what
they've done and that's where we see
really impressive performance per watt
numbers with M1 Pro and M1 Max so Apple
spent a healthy amount of time drawing
graphs comparing these new Chips to the
M1 and to PCS and at least this time I
think they heard a lot of talk about
those old graphs this time they actually
name drop the exact PC laptop they're
comparing it to every time
but yeah this is still a tough graph to
draw any real world conclusions from
basically I think what we're all
Gathering here is this is a really
powerful really efficient set of chips
at the high end significantly faster
than any of the fastest Intel MacBook
Pros and with potential to still have
really great battery life and so
naturally that is when we switched from
new silicon to unveiling the new
hardware the new laptops the new 14 inch
and 60 inch MacBook Pro
with all of the like quite frankly too
good to be true sounding rumors
surrounding them
which all turned out to be true which is
kind of awesome so they basically went
backwards on three years in a row of
very questionable to bad Hardware
decisions and just said oh we've been
listening you guys didn't like that so
we fixed it so these redesigned laptops
number one brought back magsafe a
magnetic pin-based reversible charging
connector on the side of the laptop safe
beloved 67 or 96 Watts on the 14 inch
depending on if you have the baseline or
the 10 core and 140 Watts on the 16 inch
for faster charging you can still charge
via USBC if you want to though then they
also got rid of the touch bar and put
back real function keys at the top of
the laptop full-size buttons too and
there's a fingerprint Touch ID sensor on
the top right hand corner you can see
there as well and the whole keyboard is
now in this black keyboard well which is
it's subtle but it's a really nice touch
I think it looks really good and then
they also brought back ports real ports
they added ports that they had
previously removed from the MacBook Pros
I don't know when the last time Apple
did this is but I'm happy to see it and
it's funny because this was the this is
the part of the event where they got
really preachy and basically patted
themselves on the back for a solid
amount of time for bringing back ports
and how great it would be to have real
ports on these machines for pros
but they're the ones that got rid of the
ports in the first place nevertheless I
won't get mad at that part I'm just glad
they actually listened and brought him
back so they brought back the HDMI port
number one which is great to see then
they also dropped in three Thunderbolt 4
ports and then they brought back the SD
card slot why they ever got rid of it
I'll never know but hell yes it's back
and then the headphone jack which is
still here also now supports higher
impedance headphones which will be
really interesting to test with some
more Pro wired headphones so okay it was
a great start they've brought back real
keys they brought back real ports and
then we get to the new improved display
on these laptops so at this point you've
looked at it probably already noticed
the notch which I'll get to in a second
but the actual display itself is also
much improved and might be the most Pro
part of this laptop especially for
people like me video creators so both
sizes now have 120 hertz Pro motion
liquid Retina xdr Display so up to 1600
nits of peak brightness for HDR so now
having real HDR screens high-res screens
is a massive unlock for creators looking
to jump into an HDR workflow like I've
been thinking about for a while so
instead of having to buy a separate HDR
display you can all do that on the
laptop which is great but also now just
having HDR makes HDR content look better
and having 120 hertz Pro motion display
of course just makes everything
generally while you're using it much
faster and smoother and great too it's
been around in the world of three
thousand dollar laptops for a while but
it's good to finally see the first ever
high refresh rate Mac be this MacBook
Pro but we can't ignore that Notch up
there so these are always fascinating
design decisions from Apple the laptop
does not have face ID like you saw the
fingerprint reader on the power button
there's your touch ID right there that's
it for your biometric authentication I
would have been totally down if they did
put in face ID for just an extra layer
of security it would have been more
secure than Windows hello which just
uses a webcam but that's all that's up
here just a webcam it is a 1080p webcam
actually it's also about time but yeah
I'm not sure why the notch is so big I
don't know why it's this wide now I love
the extra screen real estate you're
getting they thinned up all the bezels
and it's awesome that it's a 16 by 10
display underneath this Notch and the
extra screen real estate up top here is
basically where the menu bar can
permanently live and not overlap your
content but I don't know I just don't
know why the notch has to give us pixel
3 XL Vibes it is pretty massive there
are other laptops with thin bezels out
there some of them thinner than the
MacBook Pro and usually they don't have
a notch some of them have some weird
Creative Solutions I remember there's a
Zen book that has like a sort of reverse
Notch about the top and there's even
some weirder ones there's a Huawei mate
book that avoided that all together and
just put the webcam underneath one of
the keys in the keyboard so Apple chose
a notch that shows kind of a big Notch
not sure why I think this this is
probably one of those things where we'll
get used to it once we start using the
laptop and looking at the rest of the
huge HDR display and I wouldn't be
shocked if laptops in the future also
start to do the notch thing and I also
wouldn't be shocked if a future version
of this laptop did have touched your
face ID but it doesn't at this point
it's just one of those weird design
decisions Apple's just done a notch this
year now these laptops also have an
improved battery life 17 hours of video
playback on the 14 and 21 hours on the
16 which is now the longest battery life
ever in any Apple laptop and the fast
charging with magsafe is going to give
you up to half battery in half an hour
it's not bad and they also improved the
speakers and the microphones on both
laptops which I'll have to give a shot
when we get them here and test them out
but they were both already really good
on the last ones so could be even better
yeah it's just this these These are the
laptops that a lot of people were
waiting a long time for so yeah I've
told you guys already like ever since I
started editing 8K video from these RED
cameras I haven't edited any videos on
my laptop I've given it a shot but that
workflow's been really constrained and
there are plenty of other workflows that
have been really constrained on laptops
too even if you do get a high
performance laptop it's not going to be
smooth Running After Effects running
Cinema 4D with those big projects and
lots of layers that's still not fun so
we end up going to the desktop most of
the time but this could be a game
changer this could be very different it
seemed like every time Apple showed any
sort of numbers or comparisons in this
keynote with especially M1 Pro and M1
Max look pretty good I mean M1 Pro
should be awesome M1 Max should be even
more awesome and with all the
optimizations are on Mac OS and
promotion it should be a pleasure also
to use in just regular use if you're not
in your creative workflow but yeah to me
these these laptops finally really feel
like great much better Pro laptops for
professionals and I keep saying that
word but for people who have a workflow
in some way that really takes advantage
of this stuff and I don't know even even
a lot of the little details it's there
like even with the headphone jack
supporting higher impedance wired
headphones that draw more power that's
something you wouldn't ordinarily see
they just want you to use airpods Max
and get it over with but people who are
actual Pros will use their own wired
headphones and will want to plug them in
and we'll get more now out of that with
the DAC so stuff like that it's stuff
like the HDR display and obviously 16 by
10 aspect ratio now lots lots of little
things on top of the redesign and the SD
card slot every every Pro I know uses an
SD card slot in some way I'm recording
audio to an SD card right now love that
and also the fact that you can max out
basically the 14 inch or 16 inch to be
the same best version of the computer
same chip same storage same memory at
the highest end of both
is pretty sweet so you're basically just
choosing a size at that point there may
be small differences due to Thermal
efficiency but that's pretty cool too
now they're expensive of course you
could have probably guessed that halfway
through the keynote we were all thinking
oh God these are going to be very
expensive machines so it's starting at
19.99 for the 14 inch and starting at
24.99 for the 16. that doesn't surprise
me at all we knew it was coming but note
that the Baseline 14 is also a cut down
eight core CPU and 14 core GPU so you
have to spend 500 more dollars
for two more CPU cores and two more GPU
cores now I am a little bit surprised
that we didn't also see more M1 silicon
in an iMac like an M1 Max iMac or or Mac
Mini
I was surprised there weren't more M1
Max Max oh wow that's a tongue twister
but you know that's just something we'll
have to stay stay tight for also I am I
am trying to be very patient for the
eventual Apple silicon Mac Pro that's
that's the the big one that I'm
eventually going to be probably
most excited for but that's uh that's
all future stuff but either way shout
out to Apple for listening to how much
we hated almost everything they did with
the laptops for the past three years and
giving it back fixing it making it way
better us Pros really appreciate that
either way that's been it stay tuned for
the reviews and a lot more coming
because it's techtober you already know
thanks for watching see you guys later
peace
[Music]